hello grammarians today we're talking
about another kind of irregular plural
noun and that is the foreign plural
those are words that are borrowed into
english from some other language words
like fungus or cactus
or thesis or criteria
and these words come from latin and
greek respectively but don't get the
idea that you need to learn to be able
to speak latin or greek in order to
speak english no not at all but while
some words that got borrowed into
english have lost their language
specific plurals
some have not some have maintained those
plurals and it kind of depends on which
situation you're using them in
so for example in an informal context it
would be perfectly acceptable for you or
me to say funguses
like that but if i was talking to a
biologist she would probably say
fungi
if she were talking about them in a
scientific context
just like it's okay in informal speech
to talk about cactuses you're driving
along the road in arizona you see a lot
of cactuses but again if you studied
cactuses for a living you would probably
call them
cacti it's more precise it's more formal
if you like it's more polite
now my feeling is that as fungus and
cactus get more and more entrenched into
english eventually these formal endings
are going to fall away and we're just
going to have this regular plural but
for now there are still some pluralizing
rules for other languages that it helps
to know
so let's go through those so i made this
little chart to go over the six most
common latin and greek irregular plurals
that you're going to encounter in
english
so the first one is final a to final ae
so you take a word like larva in the
singular which is like a little baby bug
like an ant larva or a caterpillar larva
and the traditional irregular plural the
latin plural of that is larvae
ae but the regular plural that will
probably get more popular over time is
larva's
but this is the first one a to ae larva
to larvae just like antenna becomes
antennae
secondly the ending change from final us
to final i which we find in a word like
fungus is the singular and then the
irregular plural of that is fungi
and as i said before there are some
people who use funguses but again that
regular plural is more informal
this next one is also latin and it's the
change from final um to final a
so we take a word like datum which is a
single unit of data
so the plural of data so we change
singular datum to plural data and there
is no
accepted you wouldn't say the data's
that is not a an accepted regular plural
i think what's going to happen instead
is that datum is going to fall away but
again it hasn't really happened yet not
in a not in a formal context anyway
this next one is also latin and it's
final ex or final ix to final i-c-e-s so
if you take a word like index or matrix
the plural of that is not indexes but
indices
indexes is again the informal regular
plural
but indices is the more formal irregular
plural likewise
matrices this one is greek and it's the
change from final is to final e s as in
the word thesis in the singular becoming
theses in the irregular plural
the regular plural this i do not care
for because it is thesises and i think
that sounds silly
but thinking something is silly is no
reason to stand to thwart the tide of
linguistic change grumble grumble
this last one is also greek and it's the
change from singular o n to plural a so
we take the this word like criterion or
phenomenon
and in the plural it is criteria
or phenomena
and as with datum there isn't really a
a regular plural form for criteria
nobody says criterions because the word
criteria is so much better known
anyway so these are six little ending
rules but like i said you don't need to
learn latin or greek in order to make
sense of english but having these six
rules in your tool belt if you use them
judiciously will probably come in handy
but for real if you see a word and you
don't know its derivation
just trust your instincts and give it a
regular plural just tack on an s
you know the world's not going to end no
harm will come to you
and if you're curious you can look it up
later
you can learn anything
david out